well tariq i want to talk to you about
another relationship that has made a lot
of headlines
your relationship with your brother dean
i know you knew this was coming
um you claimed that he actually quit
filming pillow talk with you due to
jealousy and ego
is there still bad blood between you two
absolutely
um there's bad blood there's bad blood
from him to me and
um you know y'all find out
um in the future y'all will find out the
details of it but
um you know it it got really ugly
and i don't even know if i'm supposed to
say this or not but
you know if y'all want to break the
headline yeah he tried to get
them to fire me he told them
that if he couldn't do pillow talk alone
because he was the star
right that he quit so
news flash dean tried to get his brother
fired off a pillow talk
period in the story now if you don't
call that backstab
right and how did you how did you how
did you find that out
i found it out um not from him
let's just say that i didn't find it out
from him third parties had to tell me
but was it a credible source it was
absolutely a hundred percent credible i
verified
so if it was from a source
that knew because he told them basically
to tell me
and these and these were people behind
the scenes of the show
well i'm curious to know how does it
feel
how does it feel having fame cause such
a huge
divide between you and your brother
because some people look at it like okay
wow fame destroyed this relationship
essentially
you know what though uh if i can keep it
all the way a thou well
but down well means like you know keep
it 100
yeah but i say people a thousand but you
know i'm a little bit hood so i gotta
dow
wow you anyway um
uh you know to keep it all the way real
i feel like
you know if us you know being on tv and
him getting a little taste of fame
you know could really really you know
have him pull the daggers out on his own
brother
then we wasn't brothers in the beginning
have you ever encountered something like
this before the
the cameras came in between dean and i
yeah or it was just like something that
blindsided you
absolutely out of the blue
just the same as the meteor that came
and wiped out the
that's how i got woke up wow hazel how
do you feel about all of this
knowing that your man is going through
this situation with
his blood his family if
it's sad for me because they are they
are
okay very okay before but because of
jealousy
yeah that's what we think
you know i mean of course he didn't say
you know i quit because
i'm jealous of my brother so we don't
know if it's jokes
you know we don't know what it is are
you open to
having a 100 i mean i don't know if i
don't know your life but have you
are you open to having a one-on-one
conversation
when it happened um the credible source
that told me right
your brother said either he does it by
himself or he quits
that person who is who was in the
position of power told me that
um i said yo tell him
i said get on the phone you know get
yours on the phone i don't know what
this is about
you know how at your brother nothing
your brother says he doesn't want to
talk i'm like what
i've never heard that in my life well
tell me this
because 2020 has shown us that life is
so
fragile like on a serious note
if he came around to it would you be
open i'll say this
i'll say this you know
people say blood is thicker than water
right
um but what i say you know you can pick
you can you know pick your friends you
can't pick your family
and i would say you know ultimately
i wish him the best you know i'll never
trust him again
ever you know so i don't know how i
don't know what that will do i don't
know how far that will take us but
you know when you see when you see a
completely different side of somebody
like that out of the blue and you're
like yo
we was we was just kicking it we was
just eating dinner together
right the night before you flipped them
yeah all i can do is mold the grass down
low to make sure i see the snake
so i don't have any animosity
towards him none of that
right it it was all it all came to me
you know and then then you know
he had made hazel he started to make
hazel feel like
um you know she was his sister
he was calling her sis you know and all
this kind of stuff or whatever
you know so i really said
like i've said before i really said it's
middle finger time
when she told me she was hurt about it
that's when i was like i'm no no she's
first
well do you miss your brother
um i miss who i thought he was
the person who the person who i thought
i knew
is not who i know now you know so i
missed the dude before the cameras
yeah you all had such good chemistry i
could imagine
you know you all were fun to watch for
sure
well i mean you know i mean that was my
best friend he was my best friend i
thought
you know i mean and how you saw us on
camera was how we were every day
you